this is cereth registered nurse re and
calm and in this video I want to be
going over pressure injuries formerly
called pressure ulcers in this video is
part of an Inc Lex review series over
the integumentary system and as always
I've been to this YouTube video you can
access the free quiz that will test you
on this condition so let's get started
pressure injuries have had various names
over the last several years and the past
we have called them pressure ulcers
decubitus ulcers or bed sores and right
now they're most commonly termed as
pressure injuries so what are they they
are the breakdown of skin integrity due
to some type of unrelieved pressure and
this can be from a bony area on the body
coming into contact with an external
surface which leads to a pressure ulcer
and here in a moment we're going to go
over all those common sites of those
bony sites that can lead to a pressure
injury also some type of medical device
can cause this or friction and shear
which we're going to talk about in depth
here in a moment so now let's talk about
how a pressure injury happens okay to do
that we first need to review the basic
layers of the skin so we have the
epidermis on the top then below that we
have the dermis and then right below the
dermis we have the capillary bed which
feeds and perfuses and supplies our
dermis and epidermis so remember that
and then below that we have our fatty
subcutaneous tissue followed by muscle
and then bone okay so we have a patient
and let's say they've been sitting in
the chair for a really long time okay so
when a patient studying in the chair
what bony prominence is going to put
them at risk for developing a pressure
injury that coccyx bone so what happens
say they've been in the chair way too
long
that coccyx bone is exerting pressure
this way on those bottom layers then you
have the external hard surface that
chair with a patient setting and it's
exerting its pressure down this way now
what's in the middle we have pressure
coming this way and that way we have our
blood supply
which have two pressures coming together
two layers pushing together it's going
to pinch off that blood supply to that
skin the epidermis and dermis which is
going to lead to what a pressure injury
so we have various stages of pressure
injury it goes from stage one to stage
four and we're going to go over those
here in a moment I'm going to give you
examples and whenever we are looking at
pressure injuries we're looking at the
depth of how much this injury has been
affected for instance does the injury
extend down into where you can see the
subcutaneous tissue which would be like
a stage three or does it even go as far
where you can actually see the muscle
the tendon the ligament and the bone
which is a stage four or it can be where
the top layer of the skin is completely
intact but it's really red and when you
press on it it doesn't blanch so it
doesn't turn white and that would be a
stage one now let's talk about friction
and shear for a moment okay what is this
because as a nurse when we get into our
nursing interventions we really want to
make sure we're not doing activities
that caused this because that can cause
a pressure injury so what this is it's
where you have the bone right here the
bottom layer moving in the opposite
direction of the skin so how can this
happen big common way this can happen is
if your patients sitting in bed and
they're sliding down in the bed so what
happens is that we'll say the coccyx
again is moving this way and as they
slide down the pit the skin is moving
this way so when you have these two
forces going opposite direction what's
going to happen to that middle layer
that's so important that perfuses our
dermis and epidermis it's going to tear
it's going to mess up then we get
decreased perfusion which makes a great
site for a pressure injury now let's
talk about risk factors that can
increase a patient's risk of developing
a pressure injury and I would really
remit
these risk factors because exams love to
throw out all these patients that could
have a potential risk for a pressure
injury and you need to select the one
that has the most risk okay so whenever
you're looking at those options or
you're thinking about this try to think
about it this way okay think of the
patient population that can't relieve
their own self pressure like they can't
shift their weight in bed or they have
decreased sensory perception which would
lead to them not really being able to
shift their own way or they've had some
type of injury that prevents them from
doing that
have some type of medical device they're
wearing like the splint the nasal
cannula really with the nasal cannula I
have seen where they have wore pressure
injuries on the ear so you have to watch
out for that or they have decreased skin
integrity so poor nutrition is
definitely a huge risk for developing a
pressure injury so look out for those
low weights low body mass indexes
because I decreases our skin integrity
if the patient is in mobile they're just
not getting out of bed they can't move
they can't get up and walk they're
confined to that bed which requires you
to turn them every two hours definitely
at risk they have some type of neuro
issue where they have decreased level of
consciousness this could be because
they're sedated we're in a sense causing
their decreased level of consciousness
because we're treating them for
something else or they have their labs
are thrown off or they're just not aware
of where they're at or they have some
type of spinal injury maybe in
quadriplegic something like that where
they can't actually feel that pressure
and shifts their own weight diabetics
are at risk for this so if they're in
mobile have neuro issues poor nutrition
really huge candidate for a pressure
ulcer because why is that well diabetics
we know that they have decreased
perception of sensory so patients who
don't have diabetes they can feel you
know if they step on something with
their feet more than a person who has
diabetes they may not know that they've
injured their foot and they have
decreased perfusion so their epidermis
and dermis isn't going to be as perfused
as well as
one who doesn't have diabetes okay so
who is incontinent this can be a stool
or urine if that sets on the skin long
they have that pressure building that
increases the risk of a pressure injury
and activities that cause that friction
and shear that we just talked about so
preventing your patient from sliding
down in the bed and when you do have to
move your patient up in bed because a
lot of times patients are they get down
in the bed instead of dragging them up
in the bed lifting them and moving them
instead of making it where you would
drag them because again the bones gonna
move in another direction the top layer
of skin is going to move on the other in
a tarry capillary bed and increase the
risk of a pressure injury now let's talk
about the top sites for pressure injury
and whenever you are a nurse taking care
of your patient you want to be aware of
what position the patient's in and where
those bony prominences are at so you can
be thinking of okay I want to make sure
that they're not having pressure
injuries at these locations and these
locations include the heels and the
ankles as well as the hips the sacral
area on the back the elbows and
shoulders the inside of the knees along
with the occipital area and the ears now
is like a little quiz okay we have this
patient they're laying on their left
side so where do you think they're gonna
be at most risk for a pressure injury so
whenever we look at this we need to
think okay what areas are going to be
either coming into contact with the hard
service that bony prominence or are they
going to be too bony prominences coming
together because I can also lead to a
pressure injury as well
okay well suffer start from head to toe
and work our way down so the ear
definitely because laying right there
that's a perfect area for a pressure
injury next move down our shoulder hard
bony area on your shoulder right there
can lead to one and then as we move down
our hips big bony area that's just a
perfect site for a pressure in
jury the knees whenever you're laying in
this position not only with the knee
coming into contact with the surface but
the two knees actually coming together
can cause that along with the ankles
which is another side so the ankles
coming together or the ankle lane on the
bed so it would be good to get this
patient like a wedge pillow to help
prevent that from happening now let's
talk about staging of pressure injuries
and these stages are based on the
national pressure injury staging system
okay Stage one this is where the skin is
completely intact so that top layer is
not going to be broken and this area is
going to be very red but the key would
say to one that you need to remember is
that it doesn't blanch so if you touched
on this red area it would not turn white
it would stay the same color and here is
an example of a stage one if you pressed
here on the hill where it's extremely
red it would not blanch next h2 this is
where the skin is visibly damaged it's
not going to be intact and you are going
to see partial loss of the dermis so
extends down to the dermis but it will
not extend down into the sub-q fatty
tissue that will not be visible and it
can have a wound that can be a
superficial red or pink open ulcer or it
may have a formation of an open or
closed blister and here's an example of
what a stage two looks like next is
stage three this is where the skin is
visibly damaged and not intact with full
loss of skin tissue now you may see the
sub-q fatty tissue which will be
yellowish or white in that wound bed and
the wound edges can be rolled away like
called
epi ball now the big thing about this is
that you are not going to see
tendon muscle ligament that will not be
visible and here is an example of a
stage 3 and notice at the top that the
wound edges have began to roll away and
one of the most severe stages of a
pressure injury is a stage 4 this is
where the skin is visibly damaged of
course and there is also full loss of
skin tissue but the thing is is that it
will expose bone muscle tendon and
ligaments you will be able to see this
and here is an example of a stage 4
pressure injury and as you can see you
can see the bone very clearly in this
image now let's look at an unstageable
pressure injury ok the reason it's
unstageable you can't actually stage it
as a 1 2 3 or 4 is because there slough
or eschar covering a full thickness
ulcer and Slough is yellowish 10
substance and you can see that here in
this picture and eschar is like a
brownish black area covering the womb so
because that's in the way you can't
actually see the depth of the wound so
it's labeled unstageable and lastly
let's look at a deep tissue injury ok
this presents as a purplish or blackish
area over the skin nice intact and the
fatty tissue is injured below and you
may also see where there's been like
this blackish full looking blistered
area I've seen this on the hills and
when you touch this palpate it it will
feel heavy and spongy and this is a deep
tissue injury now let's talk about
nursing interventions what are we gonna
do for this patient who has a pressure
injury ok our role includes prevention
detection and wound care so what we're
going to be doing is whenever we receive
a patient whenever we go in to do that
head-to-toe assessment we are going to
really concentrate on that skin
integrity and making sure that they have
no pressure injuries already there and
if they do we
immediately want to document that and we
want to include the stage or the
pressure injury the size the color the
drainage also notify the physician if
it's a really bad wound that can be
cultured you want to notify them about
that so you can possibly obtain a order
for a wound culture also if the wound is
very severe you may need an order to
contact the wound care team so they can
come assess that wound and prescribe
treatment another thing is every shift
you're going to be assessing the
patient's risk factors for a potential
pressure injury and in the hospital with
every shift when we document we use the
Braden scale and the Braden scale looks
at six categories it looks at sensory
moisture activity mobility nutrition and
friction and share which is what we
really talked about at the beginning of
the lecture with those risk factors so
we're looking at all those and based on
what they score it can go from zero to
23 with a nine or less meaning a very
high risk in 19 to 23 there's really no
risk at all now in our plan of care what
we want to include are things that will
help us prevent any further breakdown of
a pressure injury that is already there
or to help prevent one altogether so
some things we can include as keeping
the skin dry and clean the patients
incontinent you want or excessively
sweaty you want to use barrier creams to
help protect that skin especially where
pressure injury can develop make sure
they always are wearing a clean gown dry
linens
and preferably wrinkle free also turn
them every two hours that's the minimum
we want to make sure that if they can't
alleviate their own pressure on those
bony prominences that we're helping them
do that watch for those activities that
produce friction and shear and we talked
about that earlier in the leg
and one thing with the patients who
really slide down in the bed what can
help is as you put the head of the bed
up put their foot of the bed up a little
bit so they're not gonna just be sliding
down and said when you have the foot up
a little bit that will help prevent them
sliding down and another thing is that
you can get your patient special devices
like there are air beds made for
patients who are at risk for pressure
injuries if they are just at a huge risk
they score really low on the Braden
scale you can get them beds that will
cycle on and off with these air pockets
that will help alleviate the pressure on
those bony prominences also you can get
patients Hill boots to help prevent
those hills from just setting on the bed
elbow pads as well as wedges to keep
those knees and ankles separated gel
cushions for the bottom if they set in
the bedside chair a lot or they set up
in bed or they're in the wheelchair that
can help prevent pressure injuries
developing there some other things
include to routinely assess the skin
integrity around those medical devices
especially with the nasal canula any
type of mask they're wearing or if they
have splints like our ortho devices it
can really put pressure on the skin and
lead to a pressure injury so make sure
you're always assessing that also the
physician may order to consult nutrition
or you can recommend that especially if
your patient has poor nutrition and it's
going to alter the way that they're
wound is going to heal so they can
prescribe high caloric diets with all
those nutrients needed to promote wound
healing also a lot of times whenever the
pressure injury is very severe
they will console wound care which will
come in look at the wound prescribed
treatment and as the nurse you will need
to follow that out based on their
regimen that they lift them and there's
various treatments for pressure injuries
that depends on the stage and the
severity and what's going on some things
include wound vacs debridement special
dressings that will promote the wound
you
in that womb base and a neat treatment
called hyperbaric oxygen therapy and
this is where they deliver high amounts
of oxygen to that wound to help promote
healing okay so that wraps up this
review over pressure injuries thank you
so much for watching don't forget to
take the free quiz and to subscribe to
our channel for more videos